was ist da ihre analyse als hygiene
experte kann man die schulen öffnen ja
oder nein
also ich habe eben angesprochene
intensivstation ich habe noch auf keiner
hinter den dieb station irgendwelche
kinder gesehen egal welchen älter alters
auch auf den normalen cupid stationen
das heißt noch mal wo die menschen noch
nicht intensiv wichtig sind habe ich
auch noch keine kinder gesehen die
kinder spielen da eigentlich überhaupt
gar keine rolle also meiner meinung ist
die schulen können offen gehalten werden
weil wenn sie sich an die üblichen
hygienemaßnahmen gehalten wird der mund
nasenschutz wird getragen und dann auch
mal die hände desinfektion und nicht
händewaschen was auch blödsinn ist ja
wenn das gemacht wird dann kann man die
schulen offen halten das entlastet
natürlich auch die eltern ganz gewaltig
aber wir haben nun festgestellt von den
kindern geht keine gefahr aus und wer
zum beispiel noch mal da ja aber das
kind rennt dann zur oma ich denke die
oberhand also entschuldigung dass die
familie schon zuständig um darauf zu
achten also schulen auf und fertig
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren